I want to jump to this next story we got
this one from the Wall Street Journal
rep ilhan Omar ousted from foreign
affairs committee by GOP and uh you know
I don't really care they removed her I
agree with Matt Gates when he said
removing her from her committee simply
because you don't like what she said is
kind of stupid but I think he voted to
ouster right he voted in line with the
Republicans is that what it was I think
I saw that everyone did yeah all the
Republicans were in favor and and I
think what he said was this is different
this is not just removing Schiff or
swallow from a committee this is putting
up to a vote and then you know the vote
of course succeeded but here's what I
want you to see
you guys ready to listen to this no
Democrats scream no
is on adoption of the resolution those
in favor say
aye
those in favor say no
opinion of
[Applause]
the letter played again
keep going yes they're still going